so um she I also let her initiate all
the yeah do you do that or no well I'm
married I know but even marriage I hate
it I hate it I always initiate oh thank
you oh I must or I get in trouble
exactly if you don't initiate you get in
trouble it's just that was our problem
for 10 years you never initiated she
goes I want to initiate you don't ever
initiate yeah that's cute at first for
maybe the first three months and you're
like why the F does he find me
attractive why the [__] isn't he
touching no no I like it initiate what
yeah initiate it no you need to initiate
Bobby no I don't I think she's maybe
trying to play cool girl a little bit by
doing that just being like I want to be
the you know like the the person in the
bedroom that dominates but it gets old
real quick I wanted to play cooler yeah
because could you say this though if I
initiate and there's a no yeah it'll
shatter my soul for a thousand years I
know sure she's already there on
vacation with you I don't say no like
has your wife said no before yeah you
know you've gotten the headache but if
if
you say no to them though I feel like a
woman has more Crush that's a game yeah
ruin a week listen to these boys please
for the love of God I promise you you
need to initiate I should listen to Mark
Norman yes yes about sexuality yeah yeah
I don't know I don't think so I can show
you pictures
but in terms of the New York guys right
I I don't want to break your heart yeah
I'm about to though I can I can take it
you can hit me so out of the New York
boys you know I think I would go to I'll
just give you a list of people I would
go through before way before you in
terms of sexual sexual advice I yeah I'm
not a sexy guy number one Godfrey oh
advice yeah or what to do okay oh yeah
Godfrey number one Godfrey number one um
probably
um who's the one that was in the car
accident with uh
probably second yeah I'll go with his
blacks first I feel like they know I
agree is that racist no no that's a
compliment it's a compliment yeah
they're good with the last person Ronnie
Chang
I feel like I'd get no good advice no
he's a virgin yeah well you act like one
yeah yeah and you know what don't edit
that out put that out there oh yeah yeah
Yak stiff Ronnie yeah you act like you
haven't [__] dog what all right so
that's in your face what you gonna do
dog holy [__] this is like Tokyo Drift
all right Ronnie wow so my point is I
would go to them and I'll probably the
whites I would go to is Schultz no
um Schultz is a sexy guy he's got a cool
haircut yeah I dress as well he's
confident
but uh he's trying to have a kid and I
think he's they're having trouble
he's got a whole bit about it good so we
can say it good yeah
I thought you were like wild
I was like oh my God it's a great bit
all right okay he's [__] in a cup and
all that oh I saw that bad yeah Phoenix
yeah yeah it's a good bit all true it's
all true yeah yeah
um just Stefano probably not I think
you're headed to Stefano what no he's a
smart of the Italian style no he seems
gay oh wow but even better better sex
advice yeah but that's out there too you
seem gay to me dog what's up what you
gonna do
uh Giannis is another guy no Greek yeah
I would take beautiful yes beautiful
life what do I do in this sexual
situation pianist would have really
great advice yeah if no one else picks
up and then I'll call him all right it's
a mouth spitter yeah but probably you
before Sam wait everyone's a mouth
spitter
what's a mouth spinner man mouth spitter
I swallow what I did
what do you mean nothing stop stop
rewind all right what the [__]
what the [__] does mouth spitter mean
you want to tell him you just
and to your partners well you don't
hockey
some people Hawk you like yellow loogie
from the lungs the first time we we made
out what did I ask you to do
you said a punch me or something no
you wanted
yeah and you spit in my mouth yeah I
didn't like it though I like it that was
the first and last no that's not true no
one comes up you I did it a bunch of
times yeah because I thought that was
one of your Filipino Kinks
all Filipinos just spitting him out
great Ska band the Philippines
that was a Filipino King but um but but
you're the only one that ever that's
ever happened with whoa yeah yeah have
you has anybody spit in your mouth yeah
I don't I didn't like it either I like
it done to me oh okay I don't
necessarily like to do it to other
people as much as I like being spat on
have you spit on anybody nah I Spit on
the vagina yeah I may have done that
yeah yeah another thing we have in
common I was just skateboarding right
and [__] spitting in the vagina I was
just talking to it though and I was
spitting when I was talking oh yeah
you gleaked on it yeah
whatever you like clicking on [__] yeah
um yeah I Spit on that but other than
that I Spit on that yeah other than that
that's no other spits yeah on the titty
I've never spent on the titty no I've
smacked one oh that's how light you did
it this little light smack a little bit
like how penguins fly yes Penguin slime
yeah
I don't want to ruin the milk right
right I suck though I'm a good sucker
yeah I like grabbing and sucking yeah
it's fun is it fun fun and you know you
get the twirl what's a twirl man the
tongue twirl around the doorbell I've
never done that what so you just just
suck no no I've done twirl he's done a
tongue twirl yeah yeah yeah look at that
stash do it
you've gone around this world with it
you go around the world and you you nib
yeah and then yeah yeah do the old uh
window wiper oh the window wiper yeah
old timing yes very old-timey yeah
here's the kind of brush I don't like
though when there's no border I've
talked about that before and the color
of the brass when the nipple Blends into
the brush I want a border I want Mexico
United States I want to know who can
enter I want to you know yeah where's
your [__] paperwork yeah I want that
kind of Border I really do I really need
it he's gonna call ICE all right so
because when I'm in the nipple it's
different than the brush part of course
my work yes because when it Blends you
do you don't know where to begin and
where to start I mean it's like this
it's like
let's say I was I was hired yeah to
clean your house you have a house okay
do you have a house yes right but let's
suppose you had a shed in the back okay
right an Adu what just a shed I don't
know what do you mean where'd they put
the lawnmower oh okay just a shed shed
like a shed yeah body parts and a
lawnmower okay yeah yeah right and um so
you tell me to clean your house yeah as
I'm cleaning it I'll look at the shed
and go do I clean that too that's the
same with the brass right I want to
clean I don't want to lick the whole
thing right it's a lot of work uh yeah
especially with a double D hello a lot
of licking hello my friend yes
you like Borders or no I love a border
we gotta keep these people out
no you got to have a boy you want the
difference you want to know what you're
looking there yeah yeah you want to know
what you're looking at where you at on a
bumpy areola
then now we're going into [__] real
[__] right bring it on uh I'm not a uh
topographer oh okay you don't want to
read that Braille
yeah fun um no because how about this if
the bumps are as big as the actual Stout